virtual reality kurz ar verändert unsere
persönlichkeit das ist eine
bahnbrechende erkenntnis virtuelle
realität verändert uns je nachdem welche
rollen wir in der künstlichen welt
einnehmen verhalten wir uns danach in
der realität anders und dabei spielt der
gebrauch einer brille für virtual
reality eine erhebliche rolle nur dann
ist dieser effekt auch so stark zu
beobachten
die bitte persönlichkeitsveränderung
quasi auf knopfdruck klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich
faszinierendes heinz videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasst er nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen
dieses video ist übrigens in
zusammenarbeit mit der animod dem gaming
psychologen entstanden den link gibt es
am ende des videos als die erste oculus
rift brille 2015 auf den markt kam hat
sie den boom für virtual reality
losgetreten seitdem ist sie zum
allgegenwärtigen thema geworden dass
sowohl von unternehmen als auch von
spielern enthusiastisch aufgenommen wird
und das nicht ohne grund denn sie
verspricht eine revolution im konsum
digitaler inhalte
doch was macht virtual reality
eigentlich mit unserem gehirn und
stecken dahinter auch gefahren
forschungsteams haben schon 1
herausgefunden wer in der virtuellen
realität einer minderheit angehört wird
toleranter und wer im spiel die rolle
eines superhelden einnimmt zeigt danach
ein soziales verhalten und es gibt auch
schon einen fachbegriff dafür im version
oder auch immer sie wie tape wird das
genannt sie bezeichnet den grad des
eintauchens in eine virtuelle realität
auch wird sie weiterhin als das ausmaß
definiert in dem die eingesetzte
technologie in der lage ist eine
umfassende lebendige und intensive
illusion der realität zu schaffen
dabei wird eine virtuelle wirklichkeit
umso intensiver erlebt je mehr sinne
modalität angesprochen werden also je
größer die anzahl der interaktions und
verhaltensmöglichkeiten ist virtuelle
realität war lange zeit ein begriff der
nahezu ausschließlich mit videospielen
in verbindung gebracht wurde
neben dem hohen wirtschaftlichen und
wissenschaftlichen interesse an vr wird
diese bereits aber auch als
entscheidungshilfe in geschäften mit
hohem umsatzpotenzial eingesetzt zb bei
der konstruktion von auto
oder bei ikea auch im e learning kann
die virtuelle realität eingesetzt werden
um komplett neue lern- und lehrformen zu
schaffen in der medizin zum beispiel
wird sie bereits für die ausbildung von
medizinstudenten und studenten genutzt
in der komplexe chirurgische eingriffe
vorgenommen werden aber auch in der
psychotherapie eignet sie sich heute
schon zur erfolgreichen therapie von
angststörungen und traumata mit der
fortschreitenden digitalisierung nimmt
die entwicklung virtuelle anwendungen
immer weiter und vor allem rasch zu aber
ist das auch gut so kritisiert wird dass
starke massive erlebnisse und
erfahrungen weitreichend negative
konsequenzen auf die menschliche psyche
haben können so könne virtual reality
ein noch nie dagewesenes suchtpotenzial
auslösen was wäre beispielsweise wenn
man in seinem realen leben sehr
unzufrieden ist und in der virtuellen in
der virtual reality ein superheld
frauenheld oder top sportler sein kann
möchte man dann überhaupt noch in die
realität zurück die gefahr der sozialen
isolation und der veränderung des
eigenen selbstbild design groß und da
ist auch das potenzial der
zweckentfremdung von vr das eigentlich
zur unterhaltung gedachte system wird in
verschiedenen ländern von militär und
justiz bereits hinsichtlich des
potenzials für vr folter und vr
strafvollzug untersucht die konkreten
auswirkungen von vr in der zukunft sind
noch nicht absehbar aber neuro forscher
und forscherinnen erwarten neue formen
von psychischen störungen fest steht
aber schon jetzt auf jeden fall dass
immersion ein mächtiges werkzeug ist
unglaublich was damit alles in der
zukunft möglich sein könnte vielleicht
sogar die gezielte veränderung von
persönlichkeit im positiven vielleicht
für viele menschen ein riesenfortschritt
ich hätte da so ein paar kandidaten
negativen aber ganz furchtbar
aber jetzt gibt es diese folgen ja schon
bei computerspielen und vor allem wollen
die gegner ja auch möglichst immersiven
beeindruckende spiele
dafür müssen spiele-entwickler aber
einiges beachten und zwar beispielsweise
ob sie ein spiel insert oder first
person auf den markt bringt welche der
beiden perspektiven ist geeigneter für
die immersion das erfahrt ihr beim
gaming psychologen gera niveau unbedingt
anschauen also dafür
first world person und er erklärt damit
ein für allemal die heiß diskutierte
frage unter gamern nämlich was ist
eigentlich besser first of third person
also ansonsten bis dann